today on the matt wells show camila
harris was the latest democrat to visit
and pay homage to jacob blake credibly
accused rapist and serial abuser
with the canonization of men like blake
and george floyd among others
the metoo movement is now officially
dead and we'll talk about that also five
headlines including
blm fighting for racial justice by
harassing elderly diners at restaurants
and in our daily cancellation i will
cancel gender reveal parties
before they get us all killed uh all of
that and more on the way but we start
here camila harris
as i said latest high profile democrat
to meet with and
um pay homage to jacob blake and his
family after speaking with them for for
an hour
harris gushed to reporters that blake
senior known for ranting about
jews and crackers on social media and
blake jr accused of drunkenly abusing a
woman
over the course of several years before
finally breaking into her house and
raping her
are incredible watch
senator how was your meeting with the
blade family today
really um wonderful i mean they're an
incredible family
and they've endured and they just do it
with such
dignity and grace and you know they're
carrying the weight of
a lot of voices on their shoulders and
what was the message that you shared
with him
and his family to
one to express concern for their you
know well-being and of course
for their brother and their son's
well-being um and to let them know that
they have support
now blake family attorney benjamin crump
a man for whom the term ambulance chaser
was invented
issued a press release after the visit
providing more details about this
kumbaya session
according to crump uh he said in a press
release quote senator harris had an
inspirational and uplifting one-hour
visit with jacob blake jr and his family
today
she spoke individually with each family
member about how they were handling the
trauma and urge them to take care of
their physical and mental health
in a moving moment jacob jr told senator
harris that he was proud of her
and the senator told jacob that she was
also proud of him and how he is working
through his pain
now would be a good time to remind
ourselves why blake jr finds himself in
a position where he
where he must work through his pain and
that reason is that a few months ago a
sobbing and trembling woman called
9-1-1 to report that jacob blake had
allegedly broken into her home early in
the morning
digitally raped her humiliated her then
stolen her debit card and vehicle
on the day of the shooting blake had
returned to his alleged victim's house
with a knife
taken her keys and then assaulted the
police officers when they arrived
in response to the woman's emergency
call
this is the man that apparently swells
kamala harris with pride when she looks
upon him
and she's not alone not by a long shot
joe biden
had his own state visit with the royal
family of kenosha wisconsin
and spoke emotionally about the
resilience and hope and
optimism of the accused rapist and
serial abuser uh let's watch a little
bit of that
i just spent an hour or more with the
with the family as i got off the
airplane
had an opportunity to spend some time
with jacob on the phone
he's out of icu we spoke for about
15 minutes his brother and two sisters
his dad and his mom on the telephone
and i spoke to him a lot before but we
spent time together with my wife
and uh he talked about how
nothing was going to defeat him
how whether he walked again or not he
was not going to give up
we talked about a psalm in my char
church father
based on a 23rd obama may he raise you
up on eagle's wings and bear you on the
breath of dawn until we
and keep in god it's holding the palm of
his hand that we meet again
well um i think
alderman what's been unleashed with a
lot of people is
they understand that um fear
doesn't solve problems only hope does
and you keep you give up hope you might
as well surrender
now i know it could be kind of hard to
understand what he's saying there he's
talking as if he just jogged 98 miles
through the desert
completely out of breath while he's
really just sitting there but but this
is a healthy man folks
very very physically healthy man not not
physically falling apart before our eyes
at all okay
uh but anyway uh the media of course has
also played a crucial role in blake's
canonization on monday the new york
times published a lengthy article
about the suspects this is the suspected
rapist medical challenges
declaring that blake can now be the
quote rare survivor to quote tell his
own story
and it takes the article's author
nicholas bogle burroughs about 30
sentences to finally mention
that the rape charge exists and then
only mentioned as vaguely as possible of
course
he writes only that mr blake quote
pleaded not guilty on friday to three
domestic charges against him including a
sexual assault
account that's it no mention of the
specific details of the charge which are
harrowing and horrifying
no mention of the knife in blake's
possession on the day of the shooting
no mention that he assaulted the police
officers who came to the aid of his
alleged victim
the alleged victim herself gets only
half a sentence of acknowledgement
she is described as quote the woman who
reported the assault called 9-1-1
that's it that's the end of it we were
told nothing of her condition
how she feels how she's holding up how
she's coping with seeing millionaire
athletes and celebrities rally around
and celebrate the man who
she says raped abused and terrorized her
the new york times just does not
consider her physical or emotional state
relevant
and on that point biden harris and the
rest of the democrats
agree now this is quite interesting
coming from the same people who in very
recent history have spoken so
passionately about the need to amplify
the voices of sexual violence survivors
speaking of which the leaders of me too
just last week launched something called
the survivor's agenda
which is supposed to amplify the voices
of sexual violence survivors
in a video announcing the initiative
just last week the metoo
warriors said that though they've made
quote incredible strides and had some
quote amazing wins
there is still much that must be done to
ensure that society takes survivors
seriously
and that all survivors are heard in fact
let's watch that video right now
it's been almost three years since
millions of us raised our hands and
voices to say me too
since then we've seen incredible strides
and experienced some amazing wins
we've also learned that we have so much
farther to go to bring about the change
we need to see
we launched the survivor's agenda to
center what survivors in this country
care about so we can build the kind of
world we all deserve
as a survivor and an attorney who has
dedicated my career to seeking justice
the thing that i most want to see is
institutions take survivors seriously
and develop the systems that allow for
justice
and for healing as a survivor the things
that i care about most are ensuring that
all survivors
are heard and supported no matter their
zip code
immigration status ethnicity or any
other reason
there's power in our numbers and an
end to sexual violence needs all of us
we are resourceful resilient and ready
yes all survivors are heard well not all
we've always known that exceptions are
made to this amplify their voices thing
whenever
a high-profile democrat politician is
accused but over the past few months
we've learned that the exempt list
also includes women who are allegedly
brutalized by men who later die
or are injured in police custody
provided of course that the
circumstances including the races of
those involved
are politically useful to groups like
blm george floyd was convicted of
forcing his way into a woman's home
shoving a gun into her stomach and
robbing her in front of her child
jacob blake is credibly accused of the
brutal crimes already described
these victims voices are far from
amplified
on the contrary the very existence of
these women is covered up
buried ignored the champions of me too
certainly won't say their names or even
acknowledge them in passing
they are shoved to the side and trampled
over
in the rush to lionize their abusers
there are real consequences to this
first of all the continued emotional
trauma
suffered by women who must now live in a
country that hails their abusers as
heroes
is real also will the next woman
confronted by a man
she knows from experience to be violent
and volatile
hesitate to call 9-1-1 fearing that
he'll get himself shot and she'll be
blamed for it
while society wails in grief over the
tragic fate of her abuser
what if blake's alleged victim had made
that calculation what if she had not
called the police
what would the angry man with a knife
who had already stolen her keys
have done would he have done something
terrible to her
would he have hurt the children now we
can't know the answer to that question
but we do know that
if things had played out that way blm
would have nothing to say
me too would remain quiet the left and
democrats like biden and harris
would just yawn and continue along their
way
the woman in the jacob blake case the
woman who is still just
the woman nameless is not the kind of
victim
that any of these groups care about and
that's because
they don't care about women at all
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if we've learned any lesson
over the past
few months it's that emergencies happen
and uh if you're not prepared for the
emergency before it happens
well then it's it's you're in catch-up
mode and you don't want to be in a
in the mode of trying to catch up and
get prepared after the fact so that's
why you gotta get
ready wise uh now is uh
there is no better time than right now
to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options readywise has
many options like emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition they also
have
adventure meals for hiking uh which i've
which i've used many times if you're out
you know out
hiking or hunting or out in the woods
those are great as well and they taste
great too ready-wise meals are easy to
prepare all you've got to do is just add
water
a very long shelf life and ready wise
makes being prepared simple and
affordable
and also like i said the food actually
tastes good
you know due to increased demand
supplies are limited and some items may
currently be out of stock so what that
means
is some urgency okay you got to go to
readywise.com right now
you also get free shipping enter code
walsh at checkout or you can call
855-475-3089 readywise is a 90 day no
questions asked return policy so there's
no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today
that's readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get free
shipping today
okay number one black lives matter
agitators have returned to the familiar
well uh harassing random white people
while they eat dinner this is the this
is the
you know one of the one of the primary
tactics now of blm
and because blm are very tough and brave
they focus once again
on elderly people watch
[Applause]
people that built the system
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so tough really tough intimidating two
elderly people
you know big big tough guys they're so
strong and brave are these warriors
for freedom oh and by the way um here's
blm
same day same city harassing and
assaulting a black
mcdonald's manager
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow okay well so apparently every time
i've seen
you know someone shout at a mcdonald's
manager because they got a six-piece
nugget instead of an eight-piece nugget
uh that was really they were really
advancing racial justice
and i didn't realize that so when you
shout out to mcdonald's manager you're
advancing racial justice
you know we hear the word hateful tossed
around quite a bit
uh the left especially likes to call
everything hateful really
and most of the time hateful really
means something more like
uh has opinions that differ from my own
or
is more passionate about this issue than
i am that's
most of the time when someone calls
something hateful that's really what
they mean
but um what we see here
with blm this is actually
finally a a real hateful movement
movement
hateful in the most literal sense they
are filled with hate
they have only hate to offer um
they aren't trying to achieve anything
positive it's not like
this is just a misguided way of
achieving some positive goal
no there is no positive goal there's
nothing harassing and intimidating
old people while they eat dinner you
know that's that's not something you do
because you have a goal in mind
it's something you do because you hate
you hate them for the race you hate them
for their age you hate them for their
assumed socio-economic status blm is
only hate
it is defined by hate it hates white
people it hates police it hates
conservatives
i mean he hates pretty much everything
and everyone that doesn't bend to its
whims
uh it hates black people too i mean if
if you
noticed in that in that last video we
played as a black
mcdonald's manager um racial minority
middle class
you know as far as we know not a
conservative or trump supporter
but they hated him too why well because
he didn't dance to their tune that's it
you have to do exactly what blm wants
and if you don't then they hate you
and you're an enemy and you're a fascist
and you're hitler and
they can do whatever they want to you
and they're morally justified in doing
so that's the attitude
okay number two um but wait blm maybe is
not so bad after all report from the
hill reading now says
despite several incidents of protests
against racism and police brutality
turning violent
more than 90 percent of the summer's
protests were peaceful
according to an analysis released
thursday the report produced by the
non-profit
armed conflict location and event data
project
identified 7750 protests between may 26
and august
22nd in 2400 locations the report found
that about 220 became
violent a term described defined as
demonstrators fighting with police or
with counterprotesters
the term also applies to demonstrators
or demonstrations that resulted in
property damage
in 93 of cases analyzed there was no
violence
okay so a few problems here first of all
there's no reason to trust these numbers
at all period so we could just end it
there i guess
second based on this definition
what we just saw there blmrs walking
around harassing and intimidating the
elderly
that doesn't count as violent by this
definition
now it is it is violent but it doesn't
count
by this tally to be violent by this
definition you have to assault a police
officer or burn something
or you know maybe kill a you know a
random pedestrian as has happened
maybe that will count i'm not sure the
third thing though is um
even even putting all that aside let's
pretend that the actual
figure is seven percent seven percent is
a lot okay that's a lot 220 violent
riots
that even the media will call violent in
one summer
220 and you're you were supposed to be
impressed with that oh it was only 220.
only 220 violent riots in a summer
that's it no that's that's a lot
uh i am not impressed with blm's
restraint even if i pretended that it
was
only seven percent i mean the crazy
thing is
march for life pro-lifers get together
hundreds of thousands been doing this
uh every year for for over four decades
it's never been violent there has there
has been zero percent violence
over four decades with hundreds of
thousands of people
gathered together now that's impressive
okay
that is an impressive streak but when
you can't even put together
you know like four days in a row of
non-violent protests
um no that's you know what that tells me
that tells me this is a violent movement
that's what it tells me by definition
seven percent of your pro your
quote-unquote protest turn violent
that's a violent movement to be
non-violent that number needs to be
zero percent 0.0
maybe um okay
let's see number three now i don't know
where this is from or the context but
this apparently is a
well it's a vegan funeral for slabs of
meat at the supermarket i don't know
when
it happened but it's making the rounds
online pretty heart-wrenching stuff
let's let's take a look
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's emotional
um and i join these vegans in many ways
i i
am with them and i too hope that one day
the sight of a murdered cow
will be rare um
because that tastes a lot better than
medium well
and actually this is a common vegan
tactic it turns out i looked it up and
um
they do this a lot i guess i've never
had the pleasure of witnessing it in
person
when i'm at the supermarket i wish i
would but i've never seen it but here's
some more footage i found
this from an animal rights youtube
channel and in this case they
are mourning and commemorating
some frozen chickens watch
[Music]
may they rest in peace is pieces
with gravy uh as for the vegans
themselves well you know they say that
there's a mental health crisis in
america and
exhibit a right there number four the
united nations sent out a tweet
yesterday it said
the covet 19 pandemic is demonstrating
what we all know
millennia of patriarchy have resulted in
a male-dominated world with a
male-dominated culture
which damages everyone women men girls
and boys
it's demonstrating what now
how does the what what does the
patriarchy have to do with
i mean okay i i guess this is kind of
how
i remember thinking back in 2008
how the global financial crisis really
demonstrated the need for
more trans representation in the
australian
avant-garde theater scene which is to
say the two things aren't connected at
all
but i suppose i mean really any de any
event
can demonstrate any point you want if
you're not worried about things like
making sense uh number five finally for
our most important story of the day
and uh look i say this in all
seriousness i've i've of course never
been a supporter of joe biden i never
saw myself you know
voting for him i still probably won't
but um i don't know he just made a case
for himself
that even i can't ignore he
he made one point that sort of made me
pause and say
hmm maybe there is a case for voting for
him i don't know
he was being interviewed by reporters
yesterday and uh and this is this is
something that he mentioned kind of
a sales pitch for himself that i thought
was pretty persuasive listen
step or two uh what's your response to
that look at how he steps and look how i
stepped
watch how i run up ramps and he stumbles
down ramps
okay come on yeah it's a good point i
mean
if you like me have always planned to
vote for whoever can most skillfully
and swiftly navigate a ramp
then biden might be our guy i'm a
one-issue voter
okay and my issue is ramps
i want to know how fast can you walk
down them how confidently
how gracefully think of all the pres
of all the ramps that a president walks
down in a i think the latest study was a
president has to walk down a ramp
14 times a week okay so that's a lot of
ramps and
i mean do you want a guy who's tripping
and stumbling down the ramp
or do you want someone who could do a
cartwheel down the ramp if he wanted to
i just wish that i was alive back in the
19th century to see grover cleveland
because that man was a master of rams he
used to he used to
go down ramps on his hands doing
handstands one of the all-time greats
when it comes to to ramps um
anyway interesting stuff there the ramp
debate rages on but
a little bit of food for thought
something to think about with with the
rams i'm glad that biden brought that up
we're into our daily cancellation in
just one second but before we do
um listen if you uh if it's still hot
out even though we get into
september a lot of places in the country
especially if you live out on the west
coast
uh even where i live it's it's it's very
hot and do you want to get into your car
you know drive out to the auto parts
store have to deal with all of that
why would you do that we could just go
to rockauto.com it's so much easier than
walking into a store
dealing with all the questions they're
going to ask you uh dealing with the
heat and the elements
okay why do that you have access to
rockauto.com
in your pocket you have it at your desk
okay you've got a million ways these
days to access rockauto.com that's all
you got to do rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do or
like so many other industries do
rockauto.com uh what i love about it
family business it's an online business
but it's also a family business they've
been doing this for 20 years
and you can go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all the prices again the prices
at rockauto.com are always reliably low
so
if you're if you find it at rockauto.com
you can be confident
this is the best price you're going to
get for this thing anywhere
so just buy it there rockauto.com unique
easy to navigate catalog
even easy for someone like me amazing
selection low prices all the parts
you're ever going to need rockauto.com
so
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car
truck and write walsh in there how did
you hear about this box so that they
know that
we sent you let's get to our daily
cancellation so today for our daily
cancellation we're gonna be canceling
gender reveal parties um because it's
happened once again according to the
california department of forestry and
fire protection
some pyrotechnics used during a gender
reveal party caused the forest fire and
the people responsible will face
severe penalties here's the press
release that says cal
fire law enforcement has determined the
eldorado fire burning near oak glen in
san bernardino county
was caused by a smoke-generating
pyrotechnic device
used during a gender reveal party the
fire began at 10 23 a.m
on saturday on september 5th 2020
in the eldorado ranch park cal fire
reminds the public that
with the dry conditions and critical
fire weather it
doesn't take much to start a wildfire
those responsible for starting fires due
to negligence or illegal activity can be
financially responsible
and criminally responsible so uh so so
far
seven thousand acres of land have been
incinerated because a couple of
narcissists wanted to announce their
baby's gender with fireworks
instead of announcing it by just you
know announcing it
saying something like hey we're having a
girl but no they needed pink flames to
rain down from the sky
lighting up the heavens and declaring
their news onto the whole earth
uh and this is not a new thing by the
way gender reveal parties seem to start
for
forest fires every year in total about
98
million square miles have been burned
because of gender reveal parties
and two and a half billion people have
died
those are rough estimates don't google
it just just go with it for now
the main point is simply that fires or
no fires
gender reveal parties are stupid
extremely stupid for
many reasons but here's the main one and
i don't mean to disenchant or demoralize
you with this information but
but here it is nobody cares about the
gender of your baby
nobody is on pins and needles needing to
know
you might be but nobody else is i've got
like over
20 nieces and nephews and counting and
that that's one figure that is not an
exaggeration
um i i didn't have a preference for the
gender for any one of them i didn't care
that much
i'm interested to know but it would be
it would be really weird if my sister
said to me
hey we're having another baby and i went
oh boy or girl
and she said well if you want to know
come to the park next friday at 2 30
bring a long chair
uh show starts at three what why don't
you just tell me
like i'm not that interested i'll wait
for the baptism if that's how it's going
to be
but see the gender reveal party wouldn't
bother me as much
if it weren't part of a larger trend and
the trend is people in the modern world
deciding they need about 52 public
celebrations and gift-giving occasions
for every milestone milestones that used
to be normal and celebrated you know
once if at all uh and and and with an
intimate circle of family and very close
friends
but now we've decided that these things
which humans have been doing for
millennia are
when we do them anyway historically
momentous occasions and legions of
angels must come from on high
to sound the trumpet and sing choruses
of hallelujahs
consider how many public celebrations a
modern couple might have
before they've even made it around the
first turn on the monopoly board of life
first they have their engagement party
then a bridal shower then the bachelor
party
then the bachelorette party then the
rehearsal dinner the wedding
the wedding reception the post-wedding
brunch
if you're counting at home that's eight
parties just because these egomaniacs
are getting married
meanwhile nobody cares that much i mean
we care but not
eight parties worth of caring and they
aren't done yet
not by a long shot when they decide to
have a child there's the gender reveal
party
there's the baby shower followed now by
the man shower which is a baby shower
for men
or more precisely for individuals who
might be mistaken for men
then the mother gets a push present
simply for pushing the baby out
and after that there is i'm told
something called a
sip nc which is a party where people
come and see the baby
we used to call that seeing the baby now
it's a sip and see
make sure to bring a present this will
be the 15th time you give these
psychotic materialists a present
in the past year and a half and at some
point there's going to be a first
wedding anniversary party because that
also is a thing that people do now by
the way apparently
i don't know if you knew that a party to
congratulate themselves
for not getting divorced within the
first 12 months of taking their vows
people have parties for that now and
there will be you know the big first
birthday party for the child
followed i'm sure not far behind by the
divorce party
and then another engagement party and so
on and on and on until we are all saved
by the sweet release of death
of course with our luck when we die it
will turn out that you know there's a
big
reveal party for each soul to find out
if they're going to heaven or hell
like bite into the cupcake if it's red
inside and tastes like sulfur
i hope you packed your summer clothes um
and it's kind of strange when you think
about it because
by the amount of of of celebrating
we do for these ordinary life events
you'd think that we
in our culture have a serious and
profound
appreciation for their personal
importance and personal
magnitude but that doesn't seem to be
the case
i don't look around at our society and
notice a deep reverence for marriage and
parenthood
i notice in fact the exact opposite and
when you think a little harder
about it you realize that it kind of
makes sense these parties are not a
reflection of our appreciation for these
institutions and milestones
that's because the parties don't really
celebrate the institutions and
milestones themselves
the parties are a celebration of the
individuals
the individuals are throwing themselves
expensive parties
to give you an opportunity to celebrate
them
as individuals this also explains why
all of these baby and pregnancy
celebrations are popular
in well-off liberal areas where almost
everyone is pro-abortion
what are they doing celebrating what
they believe to be a parasitic
infestation well again
they aren't celebrating the pregnancy or
the baby it's the woman the person
they are gathering to stroke her ego
rather
she has called this gathering she has
summoned them
for the solemn task of kissing her ass
which these days also of course is what
almost the entire wedding reception
is designed to do as well we joke about
women being
bridezillas on their wedding day and we
excuse it by saying
well it's her big day but first of all
just because it's your big day why
should that be an excuse to act like a
raging sociopath
i don't even tolerate that behavior from
my three-year-old on his birthday
you're a grown woman allegedly pull
yourself together
also it's not just your big day okay
it's supposed to be a day for you and
the groom
and the family it's supposed to really
be a day celebrating the marriage
not you the marriage if you're seeing it
as a day about you that's a bad sign
and that's why i would recommend to any
man out there if you're engaged and your
bride-to-be is already giving off
bridezilla vibes
maybe think about getting out now while
you still can bridezillas become wife
zillas women who want everything to be
about them on their wedding day
will it turns out bring that attitude
with them into the marriage
when it comes to her narcissism and
self-involvement the wedding is just the
appetizer
you don't want to see the main course
and dessert well dessert is a
70 30 custody arrangement uh now i was
fortunate that i didn't have to learn
this lesson the hard way my wife was
anything but a bridezilla yet there are
a lot of bridezillas and brosillas out
there
our culture of self-worship is pretty
much designed to create them
build them churn them out like an
assembly line and all of the
over-the-top
self-congratulatory pageantry is both a
symptom and a cause of the problem so
i'm canceling all gender reveals
and other superfluous celebrations you
will be permitted one
wedding reception no more than three
hours in length
and that's the only public celebration
you get until your 50th wedding
anniversary
needless to say what i am theocratic
dictator this will be a matter of law
violators will be thrown into a volcano
and that will be a cause for public
celebration
we'll leave it there uh thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton